Warren Buffett Berkshire Hathaway
promising 1 million dollars a year for
life to any worker who picks the entire
sweet sixteen correctly you can get 1
million dollars just for picking the
first round perfectly
in addition whoever lasts the longest
with a perfect bracket comes away with
$100,000 Warren Buffett joins us now
good morning Warren how's morale there
at Berkshire Hathaway
well morale is very good we-we've as of
this time last year we've got about
three hundred and sixty seven thousand
people that work for Berkshire and last
year at this time we had 39 thousand
signed up this year we've got 71
thousand and we ended last year
eighty-three thousand signed up so I
think we'll go over a hundred thousand
and and I'm hoping at a minimum to write
that check for a million dollars that
where people get through the first just
the first bracket basically but isn't
this different this year that the person
who stays in the longest with a perfect
bracket gets a hundred thousand dollars
well we did that last year - okay and
two guys two guys tied and so they was a
hundred they got fifty thousand each one
guy one guy could have told you the shoe
size of everybody in the NBA and the
other guys didn't know that was around
do do a bracket no I don't they I'm
eligible but that really wouldn't make
any difference i I would I would
probably pick four of those 16 games or
but how much basketball to you I know
you followed the NBA
how much basketball do you follow
college was well what I would follow
Creighton you know obviously and when I
was it when I was younger I followed it
all I used to get out of Kansas it is a
watch Wilt Chamberlain play so I I I
loved it when I was younger now now
we're gonna go back get a bus from the
office and and watch little broad and
play early at April but it there's
there's a lot more teams now now what do
you remember about seeing Wilt
Chamberlain in Kansas oh we used to
drive down there actually we drove down
to Kansas City he could add a tournament
there wasn't it really a whole
and what I really remember about will
Jameson you remember what they said that
he was gonna have Brennan on his
gravestone mmm no at last at last I
sleep alone I was on for several things
let's put it that way if you could have
his career your career well I've had a
lot of fun I've had a lot of fun I'll
tell you the the really interesting
great basketball players that nobody
remembers that way but but Bob Gibson
when he was at Creighton was the third
all-time high score I mean and I mean he
went on to baseball they played a year
for the Globetrotters and we got out of
greatness and he he really he really
wanted to play basketball additional I
think he wrote the Lakers or somebody
yeah and and tried to get hired there so
we'd have missed a one 1.12 earned run
average if he'd gone into basketball but
he I actually played racquetball against
both Bob Boozer and Bob Gibson and
neither one of them never played a
racket sport in their life and Gibson I
mean in in 30 seconds he was it was
playing like it but plagued all his life
buzzer just bouncing me all around the
court if you could pay to do a 360 dunk
let's say something like Vince card
Vince Carter's on in the final hour of
the show if you could go to one of those
auctions and they said for this amount
of money you could you could you could
jump you could dunk for one day however
you wanted to how much would you pay you
mean competitively against if you want
to go abroad one time you know and we
had a jump ball and the corn jumped it
and then just turned around looked at me
and I was just going up with that I'm
not what you'd call full and competitive
but if you could bid on an auction item
and it gave you the magical powers that
you could dunk
would you care about that oh sure before
it East wrong form of magic so dad what
was the sport that you thought you could
play growing up well I I did like
basketball the best for one thing I was
I always
very very nearsighted so anything you
couldn't play with glasses I had a
problem which basically but uh I would I
was never any good but I had a lot of
fun and I had a great coach who coached
a this was a Woodrow Wilson High I was
not on a basketball team but he was it
was it was a coach and and and he went
to a a an archbishop Carl a Catholic
school in in Washington they won 57
state games he had John Thompson on on
his team and he had he had London
Carroll and he had it had a holiday mark
Molloy went on to be the president Notre
Dame it was a remarkable team small
school
he's Warren Buffett the chairman CEO of
Berkshire Hathaway joining us Dan
Patrick show I know we've talked about
this did you ever what's the closest you
ever came to getting into the sports
field as far as owning a team investing
in a team I bought a quarter of the
local triple-a baseball team here
because we have the College World Series
here in Omaha and it was it was useful
but we felt it was useful to keeping the
College World Series here to have a
triple-a team here and and the fellow
the donor guy and she called name Gus
cherry want to sell it anyone to sell it
to someone mall guys so we I participate
in that and kept it for maybe 20 years
and then we got a 25 year contract with
the NC double-a when we build a new
stadium so I sold her at that point just
I I want to have a very simple estate so
I don't have a lot of interest in a
whole lot of things but if I'd if I'd
stayed if I'd lived in a major in a
major league or protein city I might
well have bought something and I you
know I lived in Washington and when I
was a kid and I was actually a waterboy
for the Redskins for a couple of games
but if I'd stayed in Washington I might
have tried to outbid Snyder but but in
Omaha
you know we've got Creighton and
basketball we got University Nebraska
and football and and you really identify
with those teams so I mean I've been
approached on a lot of pro teams but
I'll let
guys like Steve Ballmer a pilot James oh
he's a friend of mine yeah but when he
bought the Clippers did you advise him
on buying the Clippers
no no Steven I mean Steve loves
basketball and he he would not have
needed any urging there was there was
another bidder where one of my friends
was involved in a group of maybe I don't
know 10 or so and I talked with her a
little bit about it but but those people
people don't advise me either on how to
play basketball
do you call I shall show my free throws
underhand I gotta tell you that hey you
probably shoot better do you need you be
check-in for no shooting yeah I'm about
about two four ten now I dread it
that's about Shaq's rate as well now do
you call the Bron when you're gonna go
out and see him in April and say I'm
bringing I'm bringing folks in I need
tickets or how does that work well
actually we call Dan Gilbert on that no
yeah but I'm sure I'll see the boss a
maverick Carter and some friends of mine
Mara one when I make the trip and I'm a
huge huge admirer of LeBron not just for
basketball but for what the guy's done
with his life I'm he is he has one
classy individual and Dan's a good
dancer good friend of mine so I can play
to guys for tickets terrified they do
now you're a competitive person but you
look at LeBron in the competent you know
he's a competitive person to get where
he is basketball wise happen how do you
how do you take that competitiveness in
sports athletics as an athlete and maybe
transfer that into business is is that
seamless to be able to do something like
that or can it be a dangerous I think I
think it's true that competitiveness
comes out I mean if you're competitive
in one thing you tend to be competitive
up and down the line you know as you
know some of the sports figures have
everybody gotten take advantage of you
know over the years but LeBron is plenty
smart by himself and but some of them
get conned one way
I mean they get the hangers-on that
they've always got a restaurant deal or
a real estate deal or something like
that but but there's plenty of there's
plenty smart - I but I'm also wondering
if you do this Warren where you have
these kids are one and done why not have
business classes that are just suited
for them being a professional athlete if
they're majoring in being a professional
athlete why don't we have life classes
in college and not you know they I they
don't want to take the other curriculum
that you have but they're there to help
the university they want to get there
one and done and then go into the NBA
what would you think about that where
it's investments if it's going to be
balancing a checkbook if it's real
estate if it's going to be hiring an
agent absolutely I think I think you're
a hundred percent right and I think that
I think that's the really great cultures
you know do some of that they do a fair
amount informally Joe maglia you may
know I mean he's he every every player
on his football team voters in the last
election I mean he he he is he looks at
his obligations is a lot more than
turning out you know a a good football
team and Tom Osborne was absolutely the
same way at Nebraska I mean he every one
of those kids with his boy and and I
think the actually I think it should be
more institutionalized than just having
the coach do it I think it's largely
been the responsibility of the coach
over the years but but to take in a
whole bunch of young kids and have them
all thinking they're you know they're
going to the NBA or you know or NFL and
and and not prepare them for life
afterwards you know maybe thinking him
tire lis as football players or
basketball players I really heard guys
very wrong the last time you went to the
grocery store just you we we were
discussing this prior to you coming on
oh I I like to go to grocery stores I
I'm involved in Kraft Heinz I've always
been interested in consumer product so I
like to wander through grocery stores
before I made the investment in Heinz I
mean for example I would go to the store
and I'd look at I'd look at the house
brand I'd look at their brand I see have
money footage I enjoy going through and
I when I go and I start out with this
big basket of course
and a baguette nothing but ice cream at
all do you bring coupons Oh Warren do
you go to the same restaurant yeah well
I you know yesterday at a friend of mine
came in it late in the afternoon and I
picked her up at the airport we went to
an ice cream shop down down in the Old
Market district and I sat there for two
and a half hours I had a I had a
strawberry soda with strawberry ice
cream and and the day before I you know
I picked up but I picked up a sausage
McMuffin with a cheese and I look at it
this way
the lowest mortality if you look at the
mortality tables for men is probably
when you're a six-year-old kid so I
figure I'll eat like a six year old do
you feel obligated to overtip do their
what over tip oh I don't feel obligated
but I but I usually do yeah
if I get decent service all yeah but I
just figure that why not you know I mean
but it's not exactly obligated but I
mean I I like the people usually get my
picture taken I have a lot of fun when I
was out of the ice-cream shop I but I
had 15 or 20 kids to drink good to see
what have ours I was there like I get
pictures taken but am I enjoy it the
Berkshire Hathaway $1,000,000 a year for
life to any worker who has the entire
sweet sixteen correctly also 1 million
dollars just for picking the first round
perfectly
in addition whoever lasts the longest
with the perfect bracket comes away with
$100,000 Warren it's always great to
talk to you and and we were just talking
about it's still one of my favorite
moments doing this when you had your
assistant called Jimmy Buffett to join
us on the show at the same time I just I
thought it was very very generous of you
to get him on and it was very fun that
was a whole lot of fun I'm trying to get
into his will actually
including favor with him he's doing
pretty well worn hey listen he got all
the commercial G's of the family I have
you got the leftover ones good luck with
the bracket challenge great to talk to
you again all right
that's a Warren Buffett CEO of Berkshire
Hathaway Hathaway I I always want I
always say to fritzy to ask him if I
should call mr. Buffett or Warren and
then he always said no Warren and I go
okay I just because I don't know 83
years of age you know showing respect
and then I think he wants to be just a
regular guy the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience